there's a big trend in investing
you can see it on this chart of inflows
to esg funds
they peaked in 2020. esg funds say
they judge companies on environmental
social or corporate governance factors
and they aim to attract investors
looking for a more ethical approach
esg funds have been around for quite
some time especially in europe where the
trend has really been sort of ahead
of where we are in the us but it wasn't
until last year that we really saw an
explosion of interest
many of these funds have recently
outperformed the markets
but regulators say they may not be all
they claim to be
we'll explain why
[Music]
the tension around esg funds has to do
with the way that they're built
there are a few strategies including
exclusionary
single theme and best in class let's
start with the exclusionary approach so
when a
portfolio manager takes an exclusionary
approach to making an esg
fund will basically decide what category
of companies they don't want to have in
their portfolio no matter what
a really common category for this is
weapons manufacturers for instance or
tobacco companies or casino operators
those types of companies are commonly
totally excluded from
esg funds other esg funds tie themselves
to a single theme
the index ticker she tracks gender
diversity
by including large companies with at
least one woman in a key leadership role
that includes companies you might
recognize like paypal home depot and
netflix
there are also esg funds tied to solar
energy and water
which promotes sustainable use of
natural resources
funds like this can help an investor put
money into companies that might improve
society
esg funds can help an investor reach
their moral goals but the funds have
also earned
solid financial returns in recent years
a wall street journal analysis of esg
equity funds
found that nearly 150 of about 200 funds
outperformed their benchmarks that's
driven by tech stocks which are commonly
held by esg funds
more than half of these funds hold
microsoft nearly half
hold alphabet in other words esg funds
are betting big on tech
but critics have questions about tech
companies inclusion
tech stocks are sort of interesting
problem when it comes to esg because a
lot of these companies do have
relatively strong environmental
practices by 2030
microsoft will be carbon negative not
just across
our direct emissions but across our
supply chain too
but then on the other hand they may have
some serious problems when it comes to
the
s component of esg for instance we have
companies that have come under fire for
their data privacy
issues we have companies that have been
criticized for the way they treat
contractors and third-party workers
but here's the catch a fund manager can
just use looser criteria for which
companies it includes in the esg
this makes it easier for more companies
to qualify even ones that seem
counterintuitive to the overall mission
one such approach is called best in
class
when we asked blackrock last year how
they were putting together esg funds and
still including
major oil and gas producers they said
that they tend to take a best-in-class
approach
an oil company could still belong in the
esg fund if it's shown to have done
better on esg principles than its
competitors within the same industry
using a best-in-class approach means
that a company only needs to be better
on esg principles
than their competitors but an investor
doesn't always know
how that fund is built the problem is a
lot of investors don't tend to read the
fine print that comes with
all of their funds when they're deciding
what to put their money into
they may just be attracted to a fund
because they see the name of the ticker
or the name of the fund itself and think
that seems to align with my investing
goals but when you look
under the surface you'll often see there
are companies in these funds that don't
seem to align with the stated goal of
the fund and that really comes down to
the fact that there's still no standard
definition of esg
or what constitutes an esg fund
these details matter because they can
change how the fund performs
but critics say that they can also
compromise the fund's stated mission
for high ethical standards recently
critics in the federal government have
sounded the alarm
on sustainable investments here's sec
commissioner hester
pierce talking about how companies are
assessed for esg funds
we see labeling based on incomplete
information public shaming and shunning
wrapped in moral rhetoric
preached with cold-hearted
self-righteous oblivion to the
consequences
which ultimately fall on real people and
it's not just the sec
the labor department proposed a rule
this summer that would make it more
difficult for 401 k holders to put their
money in esgs
the department says the rule is needed
to protect workers from investments that
aren't in their best financial interest
but pension fund managers and democratic
lawmakers say
the labor department's proposal would
undermine a tool of positive social
change
regulators are still considering whether
or not to change any rules
some lawyers and regulators think that
there should be more standardization
across esgs to prevent investors from
being misled
and others say it's a step in the right
direction to have wall street thinking
about sustainability
at all